and i worked at barney's new york the
original barney's in
new york okay the title barney's new
well i had no business working there i
had to like
borrow clothes i had to shop at discount
stores
to look nice enough to work at barney's
new york um it's kind of funny and
ironic
yes you should buy this i mean i'm not
wearing it exactly
i so i worked at barney's night during
the day and then i worked at the
comedy club at night the cool thing
about working at
barney's is that it became this like
place
for me that was sort of like a like
gauge of how i was
doing in life or something and like the
first time i
kind of had any money i like shopped
there it was kind of a cool thing to be
like i used to work here and now i can
afford something amen and then it was um
an even kind of like bigger deal one day
i i
was shopping there and the security
guard came over and he was like i just
want you to know
there are paparazzi outside first of all
the security guard like
recognized me it was like a moment and
that he was like worried about my
paparazzi
you know being amazing i know and he was
like i'll walk you to the car and i was
like
thanks honey i'm so worried i'm so
concerned for my safety
and so he i finished my shopping and i
you know i was like thank you so much
sir i'm ready to go to the car
and he like walks me out to the car
and nobody took my picture oh my god was
someone out there
[Music]
so i like get in my car and he was like
he like was so confused and
and he i was like oh that they must not
be here for me and he's like well
yeah gwen stefani is also here oh
my gosh that's awesome and it was a real
moment because i was like
oh well i guess it's not
quite there i've been offered a job
in like an interior design place i was
doing things for my thing and the lady
goes
do you have do you need like a second
job or like any and she had no idea who
i was and i was like
flattered because she liked my taste at
the same time i was like still haven't
quite made it and she doesn't know who i
am
i was like cool anyway i can keep going
with those moments yeah yep i'm still
here just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever